ce que nous dit yum c'est que le moi est
une fiction
et c'est une fiction produite par le
sentiment d'une unité entre nos
expériences
le moi c'est le dénominateur commun de
toutes nos perceptions
et bien pour Guillaume si le mot n'est
rien d'autre que le dénominateur commun
de nos perceptions ça veut dire que le
moi est une illusion
pour Guillaume le moins n'a pas de
réalité
qui a une réalité c'est l'ensemble des
expériences et des perceptions que nous
rapportons à une entité abstraite que
nous appelons le mois mais le moi n'a
pas d'existence en dehors des
expériences qu'il a vécues
et c'est parce que nous avons une
mémoire que nous pouvons rapporter
l'ensemble de ces expériences à une
entité qui serait le moins
pour yum nous ne sommes rien d'autre
qu'une collection de perception